The joe rogan experience drones.
Well we have to worry about people more than we even have to worry about drones.
Right.
This new shooting in Florida freak me the fuck out again.
Yeah,
it's happening all the time now.
It's horrific.
And the crazy thing is like kids used to joke around about this guy doing that
someday.
That was something they joked around about [inaudible].
I think that uh,
I think that the way that the news reports it and the way that it's such big
news isn't helping at all.
Because one thing that I've noticed is the whole car ramming thing.
Like that's a new thing,
car ramming where the,
a lot of the things that are happening or people just getting in a truck or a
car and just running people down.
It's a fairly new thing that started with like,
I don't know,
maybe that French one or something like that.
I can't remember the first one.
But since then,
because the report,
you know,
they're just,
they report it and they blow these things up and then bing,
Bang,
boom.
Like,
I feel like going off of the car ramming situation and the growth in car
rammings alone,
that we could sort of see how overly reporting these,
I mean,
I don't know if that's even a thing or if I'm,
what I'm saying is making sense at all,
but
I know what you're trying to say.
But the counter to that would be someone had,
what was the,
the,
someone made a really good analogy.
The point being what this is,
is only happening here.
We have to figure out why it's happening here.
So often it rarely happens anywhere else.
But here it happens pretty often.
So what is that?
Is it access to guns?
Is it mental health?
Is it both of those things?
Is it,
um,
it's just far too easy to get guns?
Is it that you're not being monitored in a sense of being talked about and
people don't want to anybody infringing upon their rights?
Right.
But if we just sat down and had a rational conversation with someone to renew a
gun license,
you know,
rational conversation with someone who doesn't work for a gun group or anything,
just someone who could just give you a reasonable reason why you should be
suspicious about this person having a firearm.
And he really don't want to do that either though,
because you can't trust people.
It's like you putting people in a position of power to decide who gets the guns
and who doesn't get the guns.
It's all very,
very fucking terrifying and can and confusing
let's seems like the Ar 15 is the one that they need to keep an eye on because
all the biggest ones are that.
And it seems to be able to mount out,
mow down a lot of people at once.
Yeah.
Semiautomatic rifles are more effective in those type of mass shooting
situations.
That's why those guys use them.
That's why they use them.
You know,
all sorts of horrific ways.
All we're all around the world.
Right.
That's what they're good at that.
So the question is,
are they too lethal for a regular person?
Who's to be carrying around
where you would want to know why a regular person wants to carry him around and
then you would realize is that really my right to even ask a regular person why
they need it?
I mean if most of these people are law abiding gun owners,
when we freak out that one person who legally bought a gun in this case is a kid
who legally bought it.
Does it,
does this horrific thing?
It's a very good question and it's a question we all have to ask ourselves like
how many times does this happen before something happens and is the,
is the answer arming the schools?
That's a fucking terrifying answer.
The putting armed guards at schools,
like I saw a story or someone had held up two signs,
which it was like a Instagram thing and so it was the,
the two signs for which one of these signs would make you feel good if you were
like a killer and it shows no weapons,
like a no weapon sign.
And then it also shows a sign with an armed guard saying that the staff is armed
and trained.
And you know,
you're looking at the two of those and you're like,
God damn man,
I don't want either one of these fucking things.
I,
I definitely don't want weapons in the schools,
but I don't want them to need weapons in schools.
That's why I don't want it there.
Yeah.
But when they,
you know,
when scenes like this happen,
you have to go,
well how is there a way,
I don't know.
I don't know what the way is other than even if you take people's guns away,
God damn,
you're not going to get all of them.
There's too many of them.
The number of guns that people have today,
I,
I think it out numbers.
Humans.
I think the number of guns like total in this country outnumber humans insanity.
Even if you are for guns,
when the number of things that can kill us outnumber us.
Are we overreacting?
Are we crazy?
Are we stockpiling for some fucking terrible collapsed there were all afraid of,
is that just start thing?
Cause we're like,
uh,
we were like the last country or whatever you think.
Is it like defensive question depute question,
like crazy scared country.
Well there's,
you know,
there's different uses for firearms and who are you to say that?
Like recreational shooters who are respectable law abiding people and there's a
lot of them out that are very good people.
They just love to shoot pistols at targets.
They do competitions,
they enjoy it.
They like being proficient with a firearm for their own personal safety and
they're having cases,
I think there was a case in shit,
I want to say it was in Ohio where some guy was stabbing somebody at a mall in
some dude who was at train shooter at one of those shooting competition things.
Shot the guy and killed him when he was running around stabbing people at the
mall.
And it was one of those things where no one wanted to play that up in the media
because they thought it was like irresponsible.
It's irresponsible to play up the idea of the rogue vigilante with the pistol.
Yeah,
but,
but that was a real guy.
Like the guys actually like kind of a hero.
Like,
if he was a in a Bruce Willis movie,
you'd be fucking pumped.
I think that guy's kind of a hero.
Like he was a normal citizen that happened to have it concealed carry permit.
Right.
Found another similar story I guess from what you're describing in Minnesota was
an off duty cop that stopped somebody that was stabbed,
stabbed 10 people.
Yeah.
It was an off duty cop.
That was the what?
The stab one.
So I got that wrong.
It was he who was the firearm instructor one.
Um,
I don't know this,
I might have been another similar story too.
It might've been,
but there was definitely one,
I'm sorry if I fucked that up.
Um,
there was definitely one where the guy was a,
uh,
one of those big NRA shooting competition type characters.
This is a terrible,
terrible tragedy,
tragedy.
And these terrible tragedies seem to keep happening and we don't do anything to
change.
Everybody's worried about,
you know,
their second amendment rights being taken away.
You know,
people worried about law abiding people who would never do anything like this,
worried about their guns getting taken away.
But they,
in all,
all of us,
we have,
we have to figure this out.
This,
this can't just keep going on this way and whatever it is,
whatever's causing it,
whether it's the way people raising people,
the way people are treating people,
uh,
whatever.
Fucking crazy mental imbalances that were not treating in each other,
whatever the fuck it is,
whether it's biological,
whatever the fuck it is that,
that we just can't keep as a,
as a civilization,
as a,
a thing that should in its best times be able to get along great with each
other.
These little aberrations,
they're horrific aberrations,
but they exist frequently.
There's so many of us.
Yeah.
320 something million people.
This is from 2015 more guns and people.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
Okay.
Oh boy.
Wow.
So the,
there's 317 million people in 2013 and 357 million guns.
That's crazy.
But then the people who are gun nuts and be,
what do you fucking care how many guns I have,
man.
Okay.
I'm a law abiding citizen.
I would never do anything like that.
That guy did.
That guy's a piece of shit.
Fuck him.
And their right to their right to,
if you're,
if you haven't done anything and you would never do anything,
why would you get lumped in with someone who has,
if you have a truck and you would never dream into plowing into a mall full of
people,
why would you get lumped lumped into the same group as a guy who has a truck who
did do that?
Why should you?
It's not fair,
but we stuffed to figure this out.
It just,
there's something wrong.
There's something wrong with his dad that many more things that can kill us than
us.
If a guy pointed a gun at a year from across the room,
do you have something in your head plan that you would do?
Oh,
there's nothing you can do.
I would do a bunch of cartwheels and somersaults.
That's always been like sort of my plan.
I feel like if I just do weird movements,
uh,
you could avoid,
this is almost nothing you can do.
Yeah.
You know,
it's um,
too terrifying,
terrifying thing.
The ability to just end someone's life with a single movement of your hand
and we learned so early on,
I remember,
you know,
duck hunt as a kid,
the Nintendo like tick,
tick,
remember that and you had a gun.
It's like we learn so early on.
Well it's just that people value people so poorly that they would do that.
This is where we have to find like the root of what that is and that sounds,
this sounds very philosophical and hippy dippy,
but
we have to examine what could possibly be inside someone that would make them
want to do something like that.
What would that be?
I don't,
I mean how the fuck does that happen?
How does it,
how were there in the same timeline?
We're not talking about like primitive Roman days or the vikings or anything
crazy we're talking about right now.
How in the same timeline does a guy like you exist alongside someone who could
do that?
There's something wrong.
There's a
Elsa thing that there's something to be said about like awareness of depression
and psychological disorders for the older generation.
I feel like in the future more people are gonna know about it and take it as a
real thing.
But I still think now there's probably,
there's definitely a lot of stubborn parents out there that ignoring go,
you're not depressed,
get up,
you know,
and all of this.
Cause it's definitely deep rooted,
a lack of structure in their lives.
You know,
stuff's gone wrong and they don't have anybody to talk to her.
Anything,
you know,
that's definitely a common thing.
100%.
The dissatisfaction with their current state in life,
their physical health,
people have all sorts of undiagnosed mental issues and maybe they don't have
insurance and they can't afford treatment or maybe they just got off of it and
they think they're fine.
I mean we know guys who did that who got off of stuff that they weren't supposed
to get off of.
And then they start getting really paranoid and crazy and then someone else to
talk them down.
And one of the things with being depressed like that is,
you know,
and like you said,
if they don't have insurance,
then all of a sudden they're like,
I don't have insurance a little did they know that it's a phone call away to get
like,
you know,
free whatever somehow or help somehow,
but also with the depression makes you not want to do that.
It makes you,
it's part of it is you don't want to sort of find help.
It's hard to reach out.
Yeah.
You know,
when I find it,
it's interesting.
That is a,
I think avoidable and then maybe we should all like think about this a little
bit.
There's something that happens whenever something takes place,
um,
where people like expect a reaction,
they expect a reaction from you.
And there's this tendency to get upset at people that are not showing a reaction
to it.
Like publicly instantaneous.
Like there's a responsibility to show a reaction.
And I've been thinking about this and I was like,
is there,
I don't know,
cause I,
I had,
uh,
put something up I think on Twitter,
Instagram,
and someone's about our show in Bakersfield tonight.
And someone said,
hey,
maybe not a great time to promote.
There was a school shooting just saying,
or something like that.
I didn't know about it.
I don't think,
um,
maybe I'd heard peripherally that something happened.
Like when I was flipping through Google,
but I didn't know the extent of it.
And then I saw and I was like,
oh my God.
Like,
yeah,
I mean that is,
um,
it's one of the worst things people can do to people.
It's to like snuff out young life for no reason.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's crazy.
It's becoming so common.
It's becoming common.
And um,
it's like there has to be a way to stop it.
It's almost like,
you know,
a way it's,
I feel like people have become so desensitized that like,
it's almost like the new super suicide,
you know,
we're very desensitized because if this had happened 20 years ago,
it'd be a gigantic thing.
They would freak people out for days and days and it would be all anybody's
talking about.
So in one sense of,
I did hear about a school,
I think maybe I'd seen something about the school getting shut down or
something.
So I'm like,
Oh fuck something to happen.
And then going into it later,
the more I looked into it,
the miles like,
Oh God,
like this is just
the most heartbreaking news.
You could ever hear it,
right?
Someone decides to go kill kids
story.
You're talking about with a Texas.
Oh,
okay.
Man,
who opened fire in Texas.
Church shooter was Harold is a Good Samaritan.
Oh,
there was that guy.
There was another guy though.
It must've been the undercover cop cars.
It was the stabbing story.
I'm on a conflated them.
I do that on occasion.
Well,
we got to got the story.
Uh,
in two instances,
someone who wasn't supposed to be there with a gun had a gun.
One of them just have to be an undercover cop.
You don't want people to be vigilantes.
You don't want people to be out there fucking Charles Bronson and that.
But
that was performing at a comedy club in Dallas a couple of weeks ago and I was
standing out front near the,
uh,
like the hosts booth for a second and they get a phone call and the guy goes,
you know what sir?
I actually don't know.
Let me,
uh,
let me ask my boss.
I've never been asked that before.
And he puts the phone on hold and goes to find the owner,
but like before he does,
I go,
what's that person asking for?
Like,
I was just curious like what he's never been asked.
He goes,
he wants to know if he can bring his gun.
He has a concealed carry license.
I don't know the exact laws here.
I'm like,
no,
don't ask the owner.
He's not allowed to bring his gun and get back to that phone call.
No,
not my eye.
Two shows that night.
Like,
you know,
concealed carry.
Yeah.
I got a buddy of mine and Kerry's ever or war.
Wow.
Everywhere.
Manna.
Yeah.
Hope I never accidentally make five of them.
It's firearms instructor now he's,
he carries everywhere.
He lives in Arizona.
You could do whatever the fuck you want.
And Arizona,
Arizona,
thanks to stay 1800
do you think if I did my cartwheel somersault thing,
it's still be able to get me though?
Uh,
maybe not.
Maybe not.
You are a clever fellow.
Yeah.